you are not seeing things
whales are falling from the sky you can
believe your eyes
it's 20/20 and we're making a video
about goat simulator it's now on PS Plus
what an opportunity to look at some of
the secrets and easter eggs in a game
which is literally one big huge secret
and easter egg
also most of these activities will earn
you trophies and achievement so this
video is a little bit more useful than
you'd think I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade and here are 25 secrets and
easter eggs you missed in goat simulator
so you've walked around goat Ville and
I'm sure you've noticed the satanic
ritual site in the hills and am i right
in thinking you've taken over for human
sacrifices of course you have but if you
haven't got around to it just yet here's
what the fifth offering will trigger you
are the one with the demon world
complete with a special move dragging
everything closer to you do you
recognize it though it's taken from the
video game Katamari which creates a ball
from everything in the world which isn't
nailed down
of course goat simulator is a less
polished version and using this ability
too much causes well causes this to
happen
we'll be coming back to that ritual site
so remember where it is near the
original spawn spot in goat Ville is
this tower
have you tried ascending it get all the
way to the top and you'll be transported
to a goat warrior castle you'll become
goat Cersei of House Lannister ha no I
didn't work that was a terrible joke of
House Lannister as she plots her way
onto the throne so you plebs bow down to
the Queen when back in the real world
your new move calls minions to your side
they don't actually do anything but hey
this is fun to be had here again near
the original starting point going to the
house with the running machine in the
garage make your way upstairs and in one
of the rooms you'll find this Walker
character statue this is a nod to the
developers previous game called sanctum
there are loads of these references
around the maps including a crash site
in the mountains over in goat city Bay
and even a toy shop window is filled
with characters from those games but
here's the best one make your way over
to the construction site and up to the
highest container you can find use slow
motion here to drop in the container but
beware the thing inside there will
attempt to punch you back down to the
ground so be ready with a headbutt this
is a life-sized version of G - but wait
that's not the end of this Easter egg
lick G - and take him to the sacrificial
area now go back to that statue you saw
in the starting house and place it here
- finally there's another statue in goat
ville - grab it's at the treehouse it's
hidden up high but use whatever means
you can to knock it down or grab it in
any way you can
next take this over to the sacrificial
altar now you have unlocked a cool
Guardian haircut from the sanctum game
and using your new tater menu you can
now play as G - whenever you want
pew pew as we are looking at nods to
sanctum go back to the house with the
treadmill and locate the bacon but
notice this is also a beacon of sorts
take this to the open area with the car
racing like it's fast and furious and
there are some crop circles to locate
placing down the bacon beacon that is
really satisfying to say bacon beacon
just here you'll trigger something but
you'll need to wait around but I promise
it's worth X
[Music]
[Music]
you're the first goat in space
congratulations look around you'll see
the entire Earth asteroids and a dancing
spaceman but is he an astronaut or a
cosmonaut I'll let you decide and to
finish up the developer Easter eggs in
go fill their offices can be found
coffee stain studios pretty cool name
who are more than happy to see you when
you go inside but there is another
Easter egg in this place
go upstairs and you'll see a TV get
close enough and you can play the goat
version of the mobile game fluffy birds
do you remember how annoying that game
was it's completely playable and to earn
an in-game trophy simply make it through
10 of those gaps
it's frustratingly hard but I'm not a
pro gamer like you I'm sure you'll get
it let's move over to the Bay Area now
referred to as goat city Bay and have
you noticed that the font is designed to
look just like GTA Vice City damn cool
touch once you've spawn in make your way
over to the wind turbines on the hill
don't worry about flying up there
because goats can use ladders in goat
simulator just like here in the real
world once on top grab the chalice
resting there from here make your way to
the other side of town
use the skatepark which looks like a
swimming pool as a point of reference
nearby you should see a dirt track with
lanterns nearby follow it up and find a
sacrificial altar where many of your
brothers have died in vain place the
chalice on the altar to reveal the
tornado goat oh and check out the mask
you're given looks more like a stag than
a goat but the mask represents your new
tornado powers tap triangle to activate
the carnage and frolic to your heart's
content
the mask also bears a striking
resemblance to the movie the mask and
one of his powers
pa rt why because I one of the abilities
you pick up early on is goat born which
sounds like this music to my ears this
is a nod to Skyrim and the almighty
Dragon Ball
make your way over to the shoreline you
will see a bridge linking both sides now
jump into the water and you should see a
sewage pipe get in there and you've just
discovered the home of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles in this version of
the game the turtles have been replaced
for probably copyright reasons but each
of the characters are here Leo Raph
Donnie and my personal favorite -
Michelangelo they're in track suit but
they do have the corresponding colors -
know what this should be a pole who is
your favorite Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle this is a truly important
question for our generation fYI the
original version of the game these guys
look like the real TMNT but their faces
looked more like Shrek I kid you not
they were also called the Michael Bay
Turtles as in tu Rd in reference to the
the film which was great
behind the wind turbines is a triple
easter egg you can find make your way
down here to the cemetery complete with
spooky visuals note that this place is
actually a pet cemetery in homage to the
Stephen King book and subsequent movies
in this world the pet cemetery is
watched over by slender man's pet the
slender goat he's all stretched and
awkward as you'd expect but he's
completely useless doesn't do anything
so here's your opportunity to get him
outside of the horror sanctum and look
here's what he looks like
on a typical day out gorgeous oh there's
one more easier egg here in the darkness
look around and you'll find a Minecraft
brick there's another - to find for a
trophy by the shoreline near the
fairground is another and the last is up
on the grass banking's
this may be a glitch but usually it's
possible to build bricks our Minecraft
when this trophy is achieved but either
it failed for me or it's been taken out
of the ps4 version that could make sense
as Microsoft owned minecraft but why the
hell would the trophy still be in here
anyway
any ideas does this work in your game
another easter egg can be accessed by
jumping on the boat in the docks
I recommend licking the boat to stay on
board because things get crazy by the
end of the journey you'll be standing on
a desert island
in reference to Tom Hanks in the movie
castaway it's also possible to find the
Wilson football he made to keep himself
company but on the ps4 version it seems
to be stuck under the boat let me know
if you can get a hold of it during the
journey over we actually pass a whale
but you'll unlikely see it because it's
so damn quick we can though swim out and
stand a goat on a whale what a time to
be alive
welcome to 22 empty if you grab all the
collectibles in the game you can to
morph into a whale Wow have you ever
read or watched The Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy in that story a huge
machine is created to answer the one
question we don't know what is the
meaning of life after thousands upon
thousands of years the answer is
revealed to be 42 leaving everyone
perplexed because they don't actually
understand the question in goat
simulator grab the towel with a number
42 upon it it's usually by the pool by
the hotel but it could be at the other
pool at the other side of the map and
take it over to the UFO in the mountains
you will unlock the hitch-hiker goats
here's the best bit press the special
button to drop whales from the sky
just like in Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy
[Music]
to have a real whale of a time
swim over to the whale drop whales from
the sky and become a whale living the
dream and finally one last word a cameo
from a Styrofoam music god no it's not
marshmallow get your butt over to the
hotel by the beach and get all the way
to the roof if you use the elevator it's
super simple but if you want a trophy go
via the mattresses and Evans
here you'll find a party going on and
the DJ MC dude is none other than dead
mouse or deadmau5 as my mom calls him
get on stage to be recruited welcome the
hottest Master of Ceremonies dead goat
or dead go are severed if you're my mum
ok there we have it to the 25 secrets
and easter egg to find whilst playing
goat simulator in 2020 I have no idea
why I made this video but I'm so happy I
did what do you think have you given it
a go hopefully this gives some context
to a game which doesn't tell you
anything about what to do in the
slightest I'm Adam from PlayStation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]